[Musique]
gabriel et thierno ray mais ahmed en
près de trois mois
des bébés en pleine santé qui visitent
le dispensaire diététique de montréal
pour que leur maman obtiennent des
conseils de nutritionnistes les trous du
libron a changé des choses peuvent
bientôt à six mois il sera temps de
passer aux aliments solides et les
parents veulent bien sûr ce qu'il ya
mieux que tel mais des céréales malade
est le premier aliment solide recommandé
et bien souvent la céréale de riz riches
en fer
l'épicerie avait révélé en 2013 que de
nombreux riz et produits à base de riz
dont des serial pour nourrissons
contenait un taux d'arsenic
inquiétant surtout pour les bébés un
bébé mange beaucoup plus en proportion
de son poids qu'un adulte s'agrandissent
et très actif et un bébé a pas le même
développement de son système de sa
physiologie pour traiter les produits
toxiques de la même façon les risques de
l'arsenic dans des produits du riz ne
sont pas tant de s'empoisonner mais bien
de développer un cancer on note qu'au vu
des histoires et des romains
d'empoisonnement nationaux il faut
vraiment difficile les concentrations
requises pour avoir un empoisonnement
donc ce dont on parle c'est le risque de
cancer qui est augmenté quand on est
exposé à la saône et qui serait ce que
l'on croît avec l'exposition
conjointement avec l'émission
marketplace de siby si nous avons
procédé à de nouvelles analyses
cette fois uniquement sur des produits
pour nourrissons ont ce produit de
céréales et collation à base de riz à
raison de trois échantillons chacun
provenant de l'eau différents acheté à
calgary toronto et montréal rappelons
que le riz est particulièrement enclin à
contenir des traces de l'arsenic le plus
toxique line organique qui est
principalement d'origine géologique est
présent dans l'eau des nappes
phréatiques
le hip hop souvent dans des sols très
saturé mouillé donc où il ya beaucoup
d'eau et à l'occasion c'est aussi désert
julio naturellement beaucoup d'art ce
n'est dans le sol santé canada impose
une limite de concentration maximale
pour l'arsenic dans l'eau et les jus de
pomme mais toujours pas pour les autres
aliments dont le riz l'union européenne
par contre impose une limite de 100
parties par milliard sur les produits du
riz destiné aux nourrissons
la food and drug administration aux
états unis recommande la même limite
sans toutefois la rendre obligatoire ces
limites affecte l'industrie alimentaire
alors aucun gouvernement ne veut agir
mais rien ne sort auteur réputé est
professeur d'études alimentaire et de
santé publique à l'université de new
york trouve que nos gouvernements font
preuve de laxisme
tant que le riz à un taux élevés
d'arsenic qu'il n'y a pas de normes sur
le marché pour réduire les taux personne
ne devait en échec à tous c'est que jean
ping le gouvernement du canada tout
comme celui des etats-unis semble ne pas
vouloir écorché lundi
tous les produits sauf deux affiché un
résultat en deçà de 100 parties par
milliard
mais les trois échantillons provenant de
trois lots de céréales baby gourmet riz
brun crémeux dépassait tous cette limite
les taux variables de 110 à 150 deux
parties par milliard
puis les collations soufflé à gré entier
choix du président biologique
affichaient des taux allant jusqu'à 200
deux parties par milliard
[Musique]
contacté à ce sujet les deux compagnies
ont voulu rassurer la population et
disent respecter la réglementation
canadienne
le choix du président affirme que leurs
produits sont totalement sécuritaire
pour les enfants et qu'ils travaillent
de pair avec leurs fournisseurs pour
minimiser ces faibles niveaux d'arsenic
baby gourmet dit examiner les résultats
mais affirme travailler avec les
autorités et les experts de l'industrie
pour offrir des produits qui respectent
les plus hauts standards de qualité
les parents devraient exiger de
connaître les taux d'arsenic dans les
céréales de leurs enfants
je crois que les compagnies devraient
être contraintes d'afficher ces taux
sont les emballages c'est une question
de santé publique et les gouvernements
ils vont rire
ils vont mettre des réglementations en
place en réponse à la pression politique
tel après sont les gens ce que les gens
veulent embellir pour le moment après en
avoir beaucoup de pression pour beaucoup
d'intérêt du gouvernement de 2 mètres
une réglementation en place pour la
saône et dans l'est
santé canada élabore un projet de
règlement visant à établir des
concentrations maximales pour l'arsenic
dans laurie vendus au canada ces
concentrations maximales seront basées
sur le travail d'une organisation
internationale regroupant plus de 160
pays qui aspirent eux aussi adopté des
limites sur le taux d'arsenic dans le
reee incluant les céréales pour nous et
pour nous
du côté des nutritionnistes
on préconise la variété santé canada a
révisé les recommandations pour
l'introduction des aliments auprès des
enfants et on favorise plus des aliments
riches en fer mais qui sont non
transformé on parle d' introduire la
viande les légumineuses donc c'est plus
obligatoire de passer par des céréales
de rie enrichi je pense que ça déjà ça
ça aide à à diversifier l'alimentation
puis à réduire le risque d'exposition
c'est aussi dans le concept de semaine
alimentation plus qu'on veut que
l'enfant développe ses habitudes pis le
plus possible qu'ils aient des aliments
moins transformés mais justement si on
voit par exemple que de l'arsenic dans
différents produits on va venir
minimiser aussi l'exposition de cette
façon là on a en plus avec les aliments
qu'on a plus besoin puis en diversifiant
aussi laissé des céréales comprend les
parents quant à eux prennent le sujet
très au sérieux on va voir pour
l'instant la cocotte alem beaucoup
ceints donc
je vais jouer julien sur le sujet puis
je vais réfléchir que ce soit qu'on va
on va faire des recherches mais c'est
pas quelque chose qu'on reprenne à la
légère
[Musique]